[Music]
I think I think it will take around 30
minutes yeah I don't expect it to be
more maybe less but you know sometimes
you know I mean I rehearse that I thing
you know we're looking at around
surgeons that's a good I thought
actually it would be 45 but I mean I was
planning to leave room for questions I
mean to keep wait is this
I'm seeing that we're definitely doing
better on the neck of the room next in
terms of so maybe
yeah here I mean we're full
you
hmm normal I spoke last year's well last
year was about the school making
recommendations without data the talk
but it was more about how do you make
recommendations when you don't have you
know prior information about the cold
style problem when you know in your user
goes to Netflix and Netflix has to
recommend some movies not really so not
for a user that is just registering
right about his movie preferences for
example in Netflix in our case I worked
with Ruby in that previous startup we
wanted to connect with some interesting
let's say groups of other people but we
didn't have any clue which groups you
would like before we had to use some
sort of information from from your
profile refreshment profile to kind of
do similarity search rather than do
collaborative filtering or I was
interested to my first time speak it was
in that room that does that room is more
serious worth noting living it this is
more cozy
the expectations from this room are
higher and as people sitting down
so we started wing at Sheetz five
we want to start when the auditorium or
finishes
hmm
but the bug
oh yeah I mean again
what
the calculations of the stock are
definitely high
it just means that people are interested
pressure in that suit
get cozy
okay hello every month so next week will
be Nick from Cedars and you'll become
comparing up you'll be comparing the
external to rejected what okay
explanatory and predictive power of
different inner model so please welcome
so hi everyone welcome to my talk let me
spend a few moments telling you more
about myself and the motivation behind
this talk so my name is Nick Soros I
studied at Imperial College where I did
my thesis in computer vision I have been
in the industry for around four years
and mainly working in startups and I
started as a software engineer but
quickly transition into data science I
now work as a data scientist at Cedars
Cedars is an equity crowdfunding
platform sort of like Kickstarter but
instead of getting a product you get
shares back in a company we were found
the founded in 2012 and we are a 60 plus
strong team
now who let me ask you a question who
here comes from would say comes from a
background of machine learning and who
would say comes more identifies more
from with the background of statistics
or economics okay and I was expecting to
be honest more of a 90% coming from the
machine learning world and more of 10%
instead of 50/50 but I still hope that
some of you will still identify with
some of the questions I had around the
differences between explanatory modeling
and predictive modeling and also share
some of the confusion my personal
motivation for this talk has been has
been known in the making since say I
always felt there was a void in my
training around the differences between
explanatory and predictive modeling
and trying to answer that question what
is the difference I found that paper
which I highly recommend you read if
you're interesting to the subject which
provided me with a which provide me with
a lot answers and and motivating me to
give this talk let me start with some
definition so we know what I refer to
when I say explanatory modeling and
predictive modeling so when I say
explain or explanatory modeling I mean I
mean building a statistical modeling to
make to test causal hypothesis this is
how I define acronym modeling and
predictive modeling is when we're doing
statistical modeling with the goal to
make predictions from new examples okay
so these are the definitions I'm going
to be using for this to the a for these
two things the talk is split in three
parts in the first part I'm trying to M
I'm trying to showcase some questions
that might arise that will show us the
difference between explanatory
predictive modeling with an example and
more close to the area where I work then
we're going to try to I'm going to try
to break down the modeling of the
modeling we do in two steps and see how
different decisions need to be made when
you're trying to do explanatory modeling
and predictive modeling and then I'm
going to share some takeaway points so
in the first part I want to answer two
main questions and these are what
techniques are more suitable for
explanatory modeling versus predictive
modeling and what our techniques are
more suitable for predictive modeling
and what sort of data questions swing
the balance between using explanatory
modeling but string the balance between
using one versus the other
so let's start with loading our data in
my area this would look something like
this bear in mind that this is fake data
but in mark a in my area and equity
crowd funding our data would look
something like this again so we would
load our data
if we wanted to understand more about in
the task at hand would be something like
understanding campaign success what is
it that make equity crowdfunding
campaign succeed so for example you
might have variables such as angel
investment whether the campaign that
seeks to raise funding comes with some
angel investment beforehand what
percentage of the of the goal of the
campaign is covered of the goal that the
campaign six-two of the money that they
seek to raise will get covered in the
first week of the campaign whether there
is any tax incentive in the campaign for
the investors or whether they have a
partner for example in sitcom or any
other sort of incubator some campaigns
come straight from those programs and
we're trying to understand when a hit
target happens when the managed to raise
this money it's okay so we know how to
do that right easy we will split our
data into train and test we will pick an
algorithm SVM it's a good algorithm it
works quite well and we will train it
and then we will have an algorithm a
statistical model that does this job it
gives us the answer given a new example
tells us which come whether a campaign
will succeed according to a logarithm
with an accuracy that we can calculate
but then an entrepreneur comes in and
ask you the question okay since you now
have a model can you tell me what is it
that I can do that makes my campaign
that will make my campaign succeed what
is the most important thing I should
focus on to make my campaign succeed or
for example asks is the tax incentive or
investor a crucial thing to have in
order to succeed okay no problem we can
do that still we will use a feature
selection technique we will put we will
pick an algorithm of our choice that is
in the category of feature selection
which will give us an idea on which of
the features over Algar and are
important first of all so we can know
and what are the most important things
an entrepreneur can do and it will also
tell us whether the tax incentive is
inside any of those
but then think about the legal
department coming to you and says
remember this algorithm you build that
we now use to make predictions about
whether a campaign will succeed that a
by which by which we decide whether a
campaign will come through the platform
or not on its probability to succeed
now the regulator wants us to explain
the model to them so Kay we didn't build
that model in order to explain the
decision that the algorithm does and so
let's backtrack and use another
algorithm that it's much more much more
interpretable we may lose a little bit
on accuracy but we'll gain a lot into in
interpretability it's an easy even if
then else sort of situation that we can
explain to the regulator we can explain
to the legal department and everyone
wins but what happened to the tax
incentive what happens if we want to
know how important is the tax incentive
obviously we still know whether it is
important we have the information gate
but how important is it and how
important is like these are the type of
questions we're approaching the type of
questions where which are more suitable
for a different type of model which is
regression regression is obviously a
very simplistic model but is a super
interpretable one it gives us the
opportunity to argue how important
specific factors are in the model and
whether there's the distinct need
significant so it not only gives us
interpret ability we know which things
are important for a campaign in our case
seed we also know whether these things
are statistically significant the game
there's also a lot of theory behind
regression on how to do that how can we
use it in order to properly explain
things what I'm trying to say is that
there are two dimensions when you were
doing modeling and this is the ability
to explain and the ability to predict
and there are some techniques that come
with that are more naturally a to
interpret so they come with better
ability to explain for example linear
regression and there are some other
models that are more suitable for
prediction and they have a higher
ability to predict by which I mean that
they have the the they have the property
to cut
caPSURE complex relationships in our
data like neural nets so in the second
part I'm going to try to break the steps
down into the modeling we usually do and
try to see how in each step of the
process of modeling we have to make
different decisions when we are aiming
to explain versus when we're aiming to
predict so first things first this is a
long debate in the philosophy of science
on what is on whether essentially the
premise is that science is an endeavor
of understanding the world and
progressing knowledge and predictive
modeling is not necessarily helping us
know more about what is happening in the
model so a lot of people are considering
a predictive modeling to be unscientific
where such explanatory modeling to be
the real science I don't share that view
but this is a debate and you can easily
see that by looking at the publication's
in specific sort of fields in academia
this is why I asked you the question in
the beginning okay so if you go in
social science is a type of a journal
for example economic psychology you will
find a vast amount of journals being a
vast amount of research being published
that is using explanatory modeling
techniques may and only few will use any
sort of predictive modeling approach and
if you go to computer a computer science
department or journal it will mainly
seem more example from predictive
modeling think machine learning and far
fewer from the explanatory approach so
there seems to be a divide between
between the two
this is fake data but you can you can
actually if you yeah I mean this is a
way you can approach that like you can
go and see how many how many of the
techniques that you identified us you
know regression or M so the difference
comes from something quite simple and
that is that when you want to explain
something okay you want to create a
construct for example intelligence that
you then in order to create a
statistical model you want to
operationalize by creating something
that is measurable for example IQ score
and it is this exact operationalization
of your constructs that creates the
disparity between our ability to explain
things and our ability to predict things
more mathematically speaking when we're
trying to model we're trying to minimize
error so what we're trying to do is
we're trying to find an F our model that
given our observable data X but come
close to Y as we know we can decompose
that into bias and variance again bias
is the distance we are away from the
actual model that is producing the data
in the world whereas variance is the
tries to capture the complexity of our
model so when we want to explain
something we are seeking to get as close
as possible to the actual model that is
producing the data that is minimizing
the bias but when we are trying to
predict things we're trying to minimize
the combined bias and variance so we're
trying to sometimes minimize variance
the complexity well model at the expense
of increasing bias the distance away we
are from the true model in order to be
able to minimize their think
regularization for example so let's go
to each step of the modeling as we know
it and I come from the machine learning
background so this how it looks usually
and see then things that are different
when we're trying to explain versus
predict
so things are different straightaway so
when we're doing pre-processing in
explanatory modeling we only care we
only care about the minimum amount we
usually care about the minimum amount of
data we need in order to be able to do
to make a statistically significant
claim to test the causal hypothesis
using a statistical test that's why
usually when you're reading some
research that has used an explanatory
modeling technique the first step is to
calculate the sample size and this is
the absolute minimum sample that the
researcher needs in order to be able to
conduct his hypothesis as you probably
know in the predictive modeling world
we're much more data hungry and for good
reason because this is this gives us the
ability to generalize to generalize more
it gives us the ability to do cross
validation things that are not of
interesting the explanatory modeling
what is the difference I think it's the
I'm not I'm not sure just copied I have
to be honest I just copied I think it's
a I have no idea I think this is just
the this is the formula you use in order
to calculate you know and when you're
trying to make a step like a statistical
sit like let's say you want to in the
p-value usually is how much confident
you want to be about the claim you want
to make in your statistical test and is
it is usually from the distribution from
the normal distribution are you running
your test the t-test a thing and the T
distribution and I assume n to be the
I'm not sure
yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure what it
is but I just wanted to kind of like
bring a formula yeah yeah and so you
yeah
then moving on in the future engineering
type of things there are two main
differences and that you need to take
into account first of all and when
you're doing explanatory modeling you're
interested in the variables that you use
have to be things that you can interpret
otherwise it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense to just have columns
in your data set that are not
interpretable whereas in the predictive
modeling side of things um you know you
don't really care about whether you can
interpret things as long as this the
data that are in your data and in your
data set I have a have an effect in your
accuracy this is referred to in the
paper as theory versus data okay so the
hints come sometimes we use techniques
in predictive modeling that kind of lose
that interpretability we you do
dimensionality reduction which is not an
option here the other difference is is
whether a variable is available in
prediction time okay so for example in
predictive modeling since we're building
an algorithm to predict something we
really care whether the variables that
we are using to build a model are
available at the time of prediction in
this example if we wanted to predict
whether a camp will succeed at the time
where it comes into our platform we
wouldn't be able to use the percent
that's covered in week one how much
money it raised during the first week
that it went live because this
information wouldn't be available on the
other side in explanatory modelling we
rarely care about weather variable will
be available in prediction because all
we care about is to really understand
the phenomenon what causes that
phenomenon then then it comes modeling
we need to pick a model so straight out
of the box there are a lot of models
that are not suitable for explain for
explanatory and modeling for example to
two main a category categories of model
that are really popular among predictive
model errs are for example in simple
method
which are methods that combine multiple
logins and produce a result like random
forests you cannot use that when you're
doing explanatory modeling because you
cannot interpret them and shrinkage
methods as I said previously if you want
to do dimensionality reduction to use
PCA straight a instantly you actually
lose the interpretability of your
variables so this type of methodologies
are out of question for an explanatory
modeling as you see there are far more
restrictions into what type of modules
you can use when when you're trying to
explain and finally its model evaluation
so you're trying to do a different thing
when you're trying to explain version
when you're trying to predict when
you're trying to explain you're
interested in finding minimizing that
bias so there are other measures you use
goodness which are categorized in
goodness they're named as goodness of
fit where you're trying to to measure
how close you are into the model you've
built whereas when we're doing
prediction the only thing we care about
is what is the accuracy of our model so
we use measures as predictive accuracy
so in this step of the way we also there
are different evaluation metrics so what
are they takeaway points from this talk
the first point for me is that
predictive models are better at
prediction again and by which I mean
that when the task at hand is to do
prediction it might be obvious to this
room but when the task at hand is to do
prediction you should use a predictive
model in reality when we're doing
election forecasting for example which
is an area populated by economists or
statisticians they usually use what
they're most familiar with which is
explanatory modeling techniques and
regression so it's no surprise that
these techniques fell short when it
comes to accuracy a lot of a lot of the
times like here the second takeaway put
a point for me is mostly for us for
predictive modeling / machine learning
type background of people and
it is at the very least when we're
trying to do when we're trying to
explain things we should use an
explanatory modeling technique and
secondly there is a there is a there is
an ethical dimension to a to what we're
doing and a lot of the algorithms that
we build are being used to make
decisions for example whether someone
will will go on trial for this exact
reason from 2018 we will have a all
companies that use algorithms to make
decisions they would have to report to
regulators and the subjects they will
have to be able to report what the
algorithm does but there is also another
takeaway point here which is that if we
don't strive to explain what our model
is doing we're not really getting any
closer into understanding what is
happening for example if we're building
a neural net that tries to other
classify an image we're not getting any
closer to understand how to work how the
brain works so I hope I convinced you
about two things here one is that
explanation and prediction are not
competing there are two dimensions and
there are two dimensions that you can
consider there are models that are
better in explanation and models that
are better to predict and I hope the
tech next time that you would want to do
modeling you would ask this question
what am I trying to model for am i
trying to explain to think and do I have
an explanation task at hand or do I have
a prediction task at hand and you would
use the most relevant technique valid
questions
[Applause]
given a large number of teachers I would
like to find a subset of them which are
non redundant that the ten features that
explain yeah so that's a hard question
thank you
and but I think this and and I was kind
of expecting someone to ask something
like that I think that the essence of
the question is the following there is a
there is there is obviously and you can
obviously do some sort of feature
selection technique okay in which you
will obviously start thinking about what
are the features that best that best
are best predict the outcome of
something but in reality if you do this
if you do any sort of feature selection
technique in order to identify what are
you know the features that that like do
a prediction you wouldn't be using you
wouldn't be using any of the theory on
how you on how good your model is in
capturing something so as far as I'm
aware the way I would go about doing
what you just said is using regression
because there's a lot of theory behind
how can i model given assuming that we
we have identified the features that we
have and the only thing we want to do is
we want claim we want to see whether
these features are statistically
significant not important necessarily
but statistically significant we will
run a statistical test for that which is
not necessarily the same type of
question that the feature selection
techniques do because something might be
important for prediction it might be
important but not statistically
significant so
is hench we don't care about it in an
explanatory type of model technique but
I think this is an open question to be
honest where you know the real question
this is how these two feel what can
these two fields you learn from each
other how we can kind of use the
techniques we we seen and we know in
predictive modeling that I perform
really well and kind of kind of open
them up make them more interpretable I
think that is the real question which I
don't think the reason I answer yet
I think it's an open question in Russian
yeah yeah so the case I've worked with
is the case I presented with the fake
data but in reality this is you know
what I do
I was actually my first task when I
joined Cedars was to explain you know
what what causes campaign success I was
also kind of progressing on the research
of some people that came before me that
used explanatory modeling techniques so
it was kind of my motivation as well to
kind of understand what's going on there
but an example of a problem which made
sense to use explanatory modeling was
the problem I had at hand which was what
is that makes you know like campaign
succeed by how much and how we can you
know influence how can we can create a
model that we will then base our advice
that we give to our enterpreneurs in
from but I think as I said like there is
an ethical I haven't worked in this
other problem but there is an ethical
thing going on here which is there are
algorithms out there that are being used
to make decisions about us every day
which are at the moment black boxes and
sometimes they don't work really well
they are biased in different sort of
ways I'm not here to say that it's wrong
what's happening I'm just saying that we
should strive to kind of set some light
into how this algorithms work we should
get better in explaining what our models
are doing yeah
even example another great room
yes sir
and so the question was whether I can I
can that an example of this of
predictive of a predictive modeling and
not being a choice agent yeah something
being statistically significant but and
I think the example and I also recommend
that you see the same talk from the
actual author of the paper I think the
example C uses is a disparity between
let's say a stamp something that isn't
statistically significant but is
important for prediction is as the
JumpShip brings is Ptolemaic astronomy
like it's not based in real theory and
what Ptolemy was saying about how the
stars are moving but it was really
useful in navigating through the sea and
doing everything at the time that this
theory was theory was involved so this
is a type of example where something is
not necessarily true and does not pass
any sort of statistical test but it's
still useful it has practical utility
yeah the other way around I think again
from what from the talk and see use the
example I think of string theory saying
that there's something that you cannot
test if it's sadistically significant
but it's a obviously of practical
utility something like that yep
you want to say the same thing good
question and I think so like okay the
question was if there's a theoretical a
constraint between constrain you it was
it was a word like between explanatory
and predictive thing I would go back to
the area I think this is where you know
my mind kind of goes when I kind of hear
that which is the trade-off between bias
and variance and where and also the
previous slide I mention about the
personal operationalization of
constructs there will always be a
difference between prediction and
explanation between because just because
the measurable data we see will always
be noisy it will not necessarily it will
not necessarily represent what we're
actually trying to measure for example
when we're using an IQ score to measure
intelligence or where you're using when
you're trying to kind of say a statement
that this cause is that and you're
trying to measure somehow there will
always be a disparity because the data
will be noisy and this is where you turn
into bias and variance and you're saying
actually also mathematically speaking
you will I mean there is a different
trade-off that is going on when when you
want to understand something not make a
prediction you want to get closer to the
to the model the model that produced the
truth not the noisiness but when you're
trying to predict something you will
always kind of minimize something else
which is what actually happens in real
life which is not necessarily the actual
model it might be something that is
closely but not necessarily the same
[Music]
when you're talking about explanatory
Barry
variable call that explains some outcome
variable and in
but in in the end it can only explain 5%
of a variation and it's very hard to
come up with elaborative laboratory
situation when we have so many different
pictures
a brain glad that there is some
discussion going on because this is the
exact thing that I want to say if you
have any you know information about this
topic feel free to kind of find me
afterwards I'm genuinely interested in
to what's where the difference and I'm
going to keep looking at it and I would
incentivize you to kind of see the talk
and read the paper super interesting to
predictor to explain easy to remember
the same as a yes
[Applause]
[Music]